hey what's going on its bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
I know what isn't am I talking about
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast dad I'm just checking in on you
I'm just checking in to see how your
goddamn day is going I know lately the
podcast has been a little bit quiet I
understand alright I was transitioning
from one part of the country to another
part of the country I didn't have my my
technologies with me speaking of
technology now these [ __ ] movies that
I want to see right now and I just don't
have the goddamn time I want to see that
Mister Rogers movie I want to see
Mission Impossible and I want to see
there was some movie called eighth grade
where they were like this is what it's
like to be an eighth grader and the
during the social media time I'm like
well I should see that you know because
I need to relate to some song people so
my jokes keep working with them me not
eighth graders but you know in a blink
of an eye the way I'm aging that kid
will be in [ __ ] college right you
can't ignore the youth you ignore the
youth you grow old with your [ __ ]
crowd and then next thing you know
you're doing shows at 3:00 in the
afternoon on a little [ __ ] booze
cruise going around the marina you know
5 foot 2 eyes or blue but oh what those
5 foots could do are you singing that
song has anybody seen my right up there
in some [ __ ] mustard stain tuxedos
yelling at your agent I used to sell
tickets at this town that ain't
happening to me I'll tell you what did
happen to me this is very embarrassing
and it's of a physical nature it's a
part of my body and this is a time when
I feel everybody has been a modem and
and we've gotten rid of the shame so I
just wanted before I tell you this I
just want to thank all of you for being
considerate and thoughtful of my
feelings
during this difficult time alright so my
sciatic nerve came back oh it came back
with a vengeance because I didn't keep
going to the masseuse to keep [ __ ]
and making sure you know that you know
whatever the [ __ ] happened the first
time didn't happen again and it got all
messed up again and we were trying to
figure out what triggers it and like
well flying helicopters you know I fly
the smallest one that exists so there's
there's nothing about it that has to do
with comfort it all has to do with
weight and balance and getting the
[ __ ] thing off the ground as long as
you can sit down they don't give a [ __ ]
if you're on a bed of nails and I think
it's just maybe that that's what's a
grating it she's like alright what else
you got I play drums I'll sit there for
an hour an hour and a half trying to
figure out how that cute little asian
girl played good times bad time so
easily effortlessly right what else all
I sit in the writers room I fly in
planes and all that type of [ __ ] and she
goes all right she was listening and she
just basically told me and you know that
my problem is is I have no ass over the
years I've just sat down so long what
little ass I had is now gone so Bo Billy
no group no gluts right as Al Pacino
would say he's got no ass right so it's
just it's just essentially bones nerves
veins arteries and skin there's no
muscle tone back there I basically have
Michael Douglas's ass in basic and state
whatever that one was when he was like
[ __ ] 65 and decided to do the yet
remember that was like a big thing with
like white guys back then be happy in an
old guy and just showing your ass Dennis
Franz on [ __ ] NYPD Blue [ __ ]
Michael Douglas and Basic Instinct one
of those movies where he was just
[ __ ] throwing chicks around which you
could never do anymore like it was he
was beating them and [ __ ] them at the
same time and I'll tell you the Broads
back in the day they loved
it was considered a hot seat nowadays aw
Jesus
what was that couch made of that he bent
her over was that [ __ ] made out of
ostrich fur that's offensive to women
and nature right now I don't know what
you do I don't know I haven't seen a
love scene in this new progressive time
I imagine the guy is sitting there with
his hands folded excuse me would it be
all right if I leaned across the table
and got a little closer to you I'm
offended anyways what am I talking about
here oh so I have to do some [ __ ]
squats you know and I got a bone bruise
I'm falling a party of people I got a
bone bruise on my left knee because my
beautiful daughter what I'm loving as
I'm teaching her how to play catch and
we got this giant bag of these plastic
balls right and I think she's
right-handed which I'm not gonna lie to
you I want her to be a lefty if you're a
lefty you can get to the show with an 85
mile an hour fastball we all know it
okay you start throwing right-handed you
got to come with the gas it's got to be
[ __ ] out it's got to be like [ __ ]
102 miles an hour at this point so
anyways she just she'll pick up two at a
time and then she runs at me and just
throws them both at the same time and I
just play like goalie and we got had
wood floors and I was crawling around on
the hardwood on my knees and I don't
know I I thought I [ __ ] tore
something but thank God yesterday I
found out I was just a bone Bruce so
it's going away but yeah so here's a big
deal I got it I have to go on the
internet and I got to make sure I do my
squats right okay and I have to get my
pasty flat ass I got to get some padding
back there or evidently this is gonna
it's going to become even worse you know
what I mean I've decided that I'm gonna
get [ __ ] I'm gonna I'm gonna get my
ass back I've decided that rather than
be that old white guy who has the
inflatable cushion that he [ __ ] sits
on I can't be that guy you know what I
mean
taking people up at a helicopter like
looking like a badass like hang on a
second guys it's just [ __ ] I know
everybody just loses all confidence does
this guy know how to fly this [ __ ]
thing anyways that's my deal you know
and I'm also a child of the 80s and you
know who's kidding who let's all be
honest nobody did legs in the [ __ ]
80s unless you were a bodybuilder
everybody just you barely even did you
back you know everybody was just [ __ ]
everybody just did like what are you
benching but you Bennett dude he put up
to 25 [ __ ] 36 times kicker tryout for
the patch Dawg right that's all it was
about and it wasn't I tell you you go to
a [ __ ] gym alright and if you have to
bench if you're waiting for the you're
gonna stand there like a line at
Starbucks at like 8:00 in the [ __ ]
morning waiting to get on the bench but
I'll tell you where there's no [ __ ]
I'll tell you right now where there's no
line you go into the leg room oh my god
it's like walking into a furniture store
right it's like going into lightly
the purple building does that place
still exist I'm making a lot of Boston
references and you probably like why
Billy are yo ho oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] the
battery thing just [ __ ] beat are you
[ __ ] kidding me I swear to god I just
can't get a goddamn [ __ ] break I'm
just gonna talk to this runs out I guess
in 43 seconds 42 seconds I'm talking
Boston ship because there are the
Yankees oh when the Yankees come to town
the Red Sox Yankees starts tonight and
price isn't in and judges out all right
but all they're missing is a hitter
we're missing our star pitcher and I
needed that guy cuz I got I got a
hundred bucks riding on every game with
these two different Yankee fans fifty
bucks each I need a price to go in there
and shut those [ __ ] pinstripe [ __ ]
down
now we don't have a race and in not
price what [ __ ] am I talking about
the other guy their price is a guy I
need not to [ __ ] alright I'm back you
know what it wasn't a battery issue it
was the memory was full full of me
running my [ __ ] Yap I'm sitting there
saying prices out sale is out is it
Chris Sale I've only been on the
bandwagon here for the last month he's
out he said he had something that's been
building something that's been bothering
him you know would she get you um he
can't play [ __ ] uh Mike judge Aaron
judge is out for the Yankees right he's
standing there like a [ __ ] Paul
Bunyan I mean how do you not hit the guy
may Jesus Christ he's like the size of
the goddamn backstop got a bone chip in
the palm of his hand isn't amazing a guy
that that [ __ ] big all you have to do
is throw a ball at his hand and all of a
sudden he can't play a game of baseball
I mean you're talking about a guy who
could literally rip the pillars out of
the [ __ ] parking lot you know then
you hit him in the hand he's like how am
I gonna play pattycake I can't come out
for the Red Sox series but you know that
is the history of the Yankees you know
what I mean you know they got a lot of
free agent guys and they're all really
soft just like all their fans out in the
bleachers all those fatties out there
that do the roll call like that's their
big thing in life hey Aaron wave at us
those neck fat [ __ ] jerk-offs out
there it's unbelievable
that you could have a team that that's
that's successful that they would they
would be involved in something well I
just don't get it I don't get the
[ __ ] YMCA I don't get why we have a
[ __ ] mascot I don't get why we sing
Sweet Caroline I don't you know what it
is that did trying to get rid of the
animals the only I mean I mean the
Yankees fence that borderline doing a
[ __ ] musical I thought it was an
advertisement for that what was that
show they had all those years with the
pup
I have a new cue that's what I thought
was I was looking at the scoreboard
gonna sit coming out of that no those
are full-grown adult males
j-jake no [ __ ] right-field bleachers
would you roll college get a line we're
gonna say your name until you
acknowledge us I know I'm coming down
hard on the Yankee fence I realize this
is not all of you guys this is only
[ __ ] 12% of you with your little gang
of baseball fans but as much as I do
that I don't think anything's worse than
watching [ __ ] dooba dooba dooba do
and that song comes on you see all those
women putting their head on their
boyfriends shoulders you don't I mean
that right there that moment there is
why women in general are not in
positions of power they sit there they
try to blame guys specifically bald
blue-eyed white males like myself which
by the way I'm really offended okay I
mean and I got to tell you something
right now if I hear one more feminists
interrupting my privilege during the day
me just walking through one open door
after another and I have to listen to
her [ __ ] rhetoric I swear to God I am
I am going to I will pull all of my
money out of the stock market and cause
it to crash money that I didn't earn
money that was given to me from my
ancestors by stealing it from people who
did not look like me okay so I'm just
staring into the stereotype oh really
bill we thought you were [ __ ] serious
what am I talking about here this is why
women and so many of them do not attain
a position of power because all you have
to do is put on Sweet Caroline and it
makes them want to tilt their head and
put it on their man's shoulder okay that
is not leadership quality okay that's
what the [ __ ] I would do if I was
running the company right now and God
knows that be all this [ __ ] pressure
as the guy who started the company too
step aside and let a woman run it so you
can act like you're [ __ ] progressive
you know what I mean where are the
ladies when it's all being built they're
nowhere to be found and then when it's
built now that you completed it we want
to fly planes too now that all the guys
died and we figured out what not to
[ __ ] do no offense to Amelia a chick
that [ __ ] also crushed it but for
some reason nobody talks about her
anyone talking about I'm just [ __ ]
around everybody I I have no problem
with people of any [ __ ] background
where am I let me uh let me let me
complete this I have to do a [ __ ]
radio tour for two hours starting at
eight minutes and how long have I done
in the podcast is it gonna work out with
a math workout nine in five are 14 son
of a [ __ ] I still got half a podcast to
go we have to wait till the end of this
[ __ ] Oh bill why are you doing a radio
tour because I'm promoting roughen gonna
be in Youngstown Ohio all right
there's no women they're putting their
heads on that guy's shoulder they put
their hey their ear to the guy's chest
after they hit him with a [ __ ] pan to
make sure it's [ __ ] hearts still
pumping okay I'm talking a tough town
and Youngstown it's gonna be great we
got pride verse prejudiced all right we
have a gay man who's fighting a
convicted felon who does not like gay
people all right we got a cop fight in a
skateboarder and then we got a bunch of
Cleveland Brown fans getting in the ring
with Pittsburgh Steeler fans now God
knows the Browns cannot beat the
Steelers on the gridiron but can the
people of Cleveland beat up the people
of Pittsburgh now you'd think generally
speaking the people of Pittsburgh are a
little softer than the people in
Cleveland all right they have six Super
Bowl titles they haven't had a [ __ ]
steel mill in generations out there okay
I've gone there it's a tech city now all
right they got all the beautiful bridges
they got rid of three
the team plays on natural grass now I
mean it's one of the quaintest towns
you'll ever go to nobody can walk up
this [ __ ] hill so they got a goddamn
elevator trolley thing that brings you
up
I think Pittsburgh is ripe for the
taking and go too rough and rowdy brawl
to order the fight I'm telling you right
now hang with you've recorded are
hanging that night with your buddies
watch it it's gonna be I will be
commentating forgot to mention that that
says a little cherry in there that I
just throw okay a little [ __ ] sugar
cube old freckles will be sitting down
on his lack of an ass evidently and I'll
be there with the big cat and the El
Prez two wonderful individuals you know
who are preventing a lot of bar fights I
feel I feel like people with headgear
and gloves are gonna be able to get all
their frustrations out it's gonna be a
wonderful night of entertainment I am
NOT going to miss a second of it and you
know I would appreciate if you guys
would order it it would make me look
good if I could help pump up their
[ __ ] numbers I love what they do over
there I hope you do too if you do please
order the fight and that's the end of
this promo how do you like that and
right the day before the [ __ ] fight
I'm gonna be in Rochester New York home
astitva GAD or at least he played with
the Rochester Crusaders according to his
according to his drum instructional
video that I actually own on VHS and on
DVD all right I never could commit to
the laserdisc I was afraid of unpopular
technologies after Robert Kelly talked
me into getting a minidisc player which
I still have with the t-shaped
microphone I can't find that but I have
all these little [ __ ] cassettes of
you know whatever many CDs of my sets
from years gone by and I want to listen
to them and people like well why don't
you take him somewhere it's a cuz I have
no idea what I'm saying on these [ __ ]
things alright I used to mutter to
myself between sets throwing out all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] and then this
[ __ ] today's climate
god knows what what the [ __ ] you said
[ __ ]
I'm we're talking 20 years ago I mean 20
years ago I was dating this woman I used
to literally drag her around the city by
her hair and nobody had a problem with
it okay you think I'm gonna dump off my
[ __ ] mini disc player to somebody
yeah do you mind it's not happening all
right anyways so I am hey by the way
guess what I made another month month of
July not a drop of booze not one [ __ ]
drop you goddamn [ __ ] and it really
affected my mood I was in such a good
mood when I would wake up in the morning
but I was so grumpy at night you know
just having to sit there and [ __ ]
stare at the wall it's weird like this
this time of day I don't miss it but at
night I definitely you know you know you
get into with your wife or uh your
parrots looking at you in a weird way
you just need something to take the edge
off and I got to tell you rosetta stone
French just isn't doing it um all right
do I got time to do one read yeah I'll
do one read and then I got to do this
tour and then then I'll be back and I'll
let you know how it goes okay everybody
hanging on my every word gee bill how is
your radio tour gonna go all right here
we go he licks everybody HELOCs maybe I
get through this in three minutes I'll
be [ __ ] great
there's nobody on the planet like you so
why would you buy a generic mattress
built for everyone else
what do you the Hunchback of Notre Dame
yeah next please mention all the talking
points below well absolutely
helix sleep matches your body to the
perfect mattress so you get the best
sleep of your life why they've developed
nine different mattresses tailored to
specific body types and sleep
preferences just go to helix helix sleep
comm slash bird take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to the
mattress that that's perfect for you
contouring to your body cupping your
balls
squeezing your lack of an ass to provide
unprecedented comfort and better sleep
36% of hellix sleep customers report
better sleep after switch
to their customized mattress from helix
sleep right now they're offering up to
$125 off all mattresses mattress orders
whether you're a sides hot like a plush
or a firm bed they got the mattress that
will fit just right get up to 125
dollars off helix sleep comm / / that's
HELOCs sleep comm / / for $125 off your
mattress order helix leak comm / burrow
alright quip everybody all right the
truth is most of us are brushing our
teeth wrong oh not long enough and
forget to change our brush on time
former porn stars gagging on it that's
because most brands focus on selling
flashy gimmicks rather than better
brushing but not quip so what makes quip
so different you may not have asked
please mention all talking points below
of course I'm gonna fist quip is an
electric toothbrush that's a fraction of
the cost of the bulky of brushes while
still packing just the right amount of
vibration to help clean your gross teeth
are you listening England equips
built-in timer helps you clean for the
dentist recommended two minutes with
guiding pulses that remind you when to
switch side next clip subscription plans
are for your health not just convenience
they deliver new brush heads on a
dentist recommended schedule every three
months for just five dollars including
free shipping worldwide qyp also comes
with a mount that suctions right to your
mirror and unsticks to use as a cover
for a hygienic travel wherever you take
your teeth and finally everyone loves
quip evidently they were on Oprah solace
I love named one of the Times best
inventions and is the first subscription
electric toothbrush adapted by the
American Dental Association accepted
sorry now it's already 8:45 I had that
happen plus they're backed by a network
of over 25,000 dentists and hygienists
and hundreds of thousands of happy
brushes he was quid a quip starts just
$25 and if
you go to get quick comm / / right now
you'll get the first refill pack for
free with quip electronic toothbrush
electric toothbrush that's your first
refill pack for free at get quick calm
GE tqu yp.com
/ / spelled GE t qu IP calm
/ / alright i'll be back in a second
alright i'm back the radio tour is over
let's finish up this podcast although
the last read but oh doot doot biondi's
be undies finish my radio tour doo doo
doo doo biondi's be undies get the boy
shorts you [ __ ] yank him up your ass
spend over the table i'll friggin bang
you like i'm clark gable with my ginger
mustachioed face i'm from the freckled
race I'm really pasty alright me undies
everybody you've heard me obsess over my
me undies you've heard me talk about how
they are softer than cotton and come
with fun new prints each month but I've
got a big scoop for you that's the skull
scoop I just literally fig picture just
like up you [ __ ] your pants that I'm so
excited to [ __ ] you me undies I'm so
newbie undies with the [ __ ] trapdoor
that I'm so excited to share with you
all me unease just gave them membership
a massive upgrade all those dirty old
hole ridden disgusting underwear you've
hung on to it's time to throw all of
that out and give you a top drawer the
refresher it deserves each month me
undies will release a new executive
print that only members can get can you
imagine all the skid marked underwear
that's gonna be thrown out because of
this promotion these could be
collaborations with artists brands or
other unique designs you are going to
definitely want to have members will
also pay less for everything on the
undies website with special member
pricing that means if you want a second
pair of undies a I don't know what that
a Braille it BR a le TT e I mean what
that is or lounge pants you'll pay less
than anyone else the membership comes
with no string
attached you could switch styles skip
the month or cancel it anytime you're
gonna love these undies they have the
softest underwear you ever put on and
they come with fun prints that you can
match with socks or a break what the
[ __ ] is a Braille it what here's a bruit
I got to look this up right now
braylee braylee braylee
but better hey by the way the show in
season 1 on me-tv of 77 Sunset Strip I
can't wait I missed the first couple but
I got I got episode 6 you know it's
crazy is it oh is that bralette how do
you say it how do you say it what say
you throw look I'm so dumb there's no
cape renunciant pronunciation acetate
here we go Brad
morality
all right I got it all right okay they
come with fun prints that you can match
with your socks are your brown lat
they come with the 100% satisfaction
guarantee if you don't love them just
send them back for a full refund the
undies has a great offer for my
listeners for the any first-time
purchasers when you purchase any me
undies you can get 15% off and free
shipping this is a no-brainer get 15%
off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on and who
knows maybe someday you can match them
to your bralet no I can't well yeah I
said no yeah Brad alright so let's see
here I did nine minutes then I did 13
minutes now I've done four minutes nine
in three is 21 and four is 25 I got
about not gonna have five six minutes
left now the five six minutes left
Oh Billy gluttonous so anyways I have I
haven't drank in like what I sit here
30:33 Larry 33 days no booze and yeah I
have really had no intentions I'm gonna
drink one day next week celebrating with
Joe DeRosa it's joe de Rosas birthday on
August 6 make sure you give old
Twinkletoes a little shout out all right
make sure you get that old saloon [ __ ]
a little tippy you [ __ ] cowboy hat
day he'd love to hear from you Joe by
the way is really an incredible
inspirational speaker on have you guys
seen Joe de Rosa's Instagram he has
these they're shirtless with his awful
body he's like he always goes what's up
hard body Joe DeRosa here telling you
that you don't have to be a slave to
your diet I don't know just look up at
Joe DeRosa or is it at Joe DeRosa comedy
just look up Joe DeRosa Instagram maybe
I can do it for you I'll make it easy
for you case you thought you're probably
pretending to type right now acting as
though you're working Joe DeRosa
Instagram he's on the gram oh and I'm
not connected to the [ __ ] internet
course why would I be
why would I in this day and age be
connected to the Internet it's just most
of the free world is most of the free
world is right there connected to it
they're control they're connected to the
you'll not only type this in here Brown
it alright Joe DeRosa
Instagram all right grandpa it's at Joe
DeRosa comedy jo e DEROS
a comedy there you go why don't why am i
- his goddamn Instagram page what does
Joe DeRosa ever done for me other bent
other than being a pal for the last
[ __ ] 15 years alright what the what
to talk about I was just promoting rough
and rowdy by the way the cop versus
skateboarder that fight is actually that
one's called Pig vs. Punk so you get
pride vers prejudice pig vers punk and
where could you go from there
palooka verse pundit an old boxer fights
a politician that could be a good one
they show you just sort of an endless
ones with with the letter P huh you
could have something with a bladder
problem P ER verse poor guy with a
bladder problem fight somebody who's
economically I in the [ __ ]
okay maybe there's not an endless one I
don't know maybe I'm wrong I'm just
spitballing here people that's all I'm
trying to do just spitballing so anyways
I got to uh I'm gonna go see
nutritionists for the first time ever
tomorrow and I'm gonna get that taken
care of I did the lat pulldown machine
70 [ __ ] pounds gradually I'm putting
it back together the way it really
happens not like on dr. Phil where he's
like oh you need to stop punching her
the fights and like somebody who I would
actually punch a woman to face the fact
that he said that like he's gonna get
rid of everything that he saw as a child
in that moment on dr. Phil it's not how
it works that's gonna be it's gonna take
that guy an entire lifetime to stop
punching women in the face or shooting
heroin or jacking off in public whatever
the [ __ ] it is he's doing right but not
old Philly Philly makes it seem like he
solves it right then and there with the
little [ __ ] catchphrase of some
[ __ ] that's why you know back in the
day when I used to watch police academy
and I would see private hooks remember
the cute little black girl you know what
I mean
it should be all mousy like the guy you
got to get his scream and in the end she
get her nerve up and she jump out of
nowhere with a gun out and she go don't
move dirtbag and then you'd see police
academy too and she'd go back to being
this little mousy person again you like
what the [ __ ] that's bad writing that's
what I thought that's lazy you gonna
have to do the exact same arc all the
way to don't move dirtbag again and I
used to think that that was lazy writing
but now having tried to to fix to
control my temper you know I'll flip out
be like I don't want to do that again
and then I'm [ __ ] you know working on
it working on it working on it and I'm
good for three weeks and then I I I have
a relapse you know private hooks is one
of the most accurate characters ever
ever written because you're seeing
somebody trying to they have a
breakthrough and you think is this it
that I finally break through and then I
nope it was just a blip now you're going
back to being mousey again and she had
to work on it through like 18 19 police
academies and I don't know if she ever
got there but I think we all could
relate simply by the fact that she was
just out there trying there you go
so that's 9 minutes 9 minutes and 13
minutes that's 31 minutes Jesus Christ
people I think I'm done here back up to
regular volumes tune in to the Red Sox
Yankees if you want to check that out
but definitely this Sunday man make me
look good make it seem like I drove some
traffic to this wonderful event go too
rough and rowdy brawl
com2 watch pride verse prejudice pig
verse Punk and Cleveland Brown fans
trying to do what the Browns have never
done on the field which is beat
something from Pittsburgh why did you
have to be mean cuz you know what it
makes people listen alright enjoy this
music and then we'll have another half
hour of greatest hits from a Thursday
afternoon podcast just before Friday
Monday morning podcasts from a Thursday
gone by from years ago or possibly last
month I don't know how it works
god bless you have a great weekend you
[ __ ] and to an end I'll be dressed in
shap I'll be in Youngstown for the first
time ever and everybody else seen
Rochester in New York on Saturday night
with the great Dean Del Ray in the
opening slot not right god bless you in
the United States of America the meant
Canada
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
like a boss say at the beginning of
[ __ ] Six Million Dollar Man you know
when that little [ __ ] kite that he's
flying why don't they ever show that
[ __ ] show in reruns that's one of the
greatest goddamn shows ever do you guys
ever see that do you have any idea how
[ __ ] huge it was when the Six Million
Dollar Man fought the seven Million
Dollar Man and he punched his [ __ ]
face off his face came off on television
in like 1974 do you have any [ __ ]
idea think about that pre-internet pre
cable pre any sort of special effect do
you look how bad the graphics were in
Star Wars the adjustments between frames
of all the tiny moving parts are
miniscule but projected to the proper
speed 24 frames per second these
individual movements will flow
seamlessly together
[Music]
actually models which can be carried in
the palm of your hand this is like 3-4
years before that Lee Majors punch this
dude who was the [ __ ] bad guy in
everything oh man
do you remember the one with a Six
Million Dollar Man fired up fought in
the snow yeah
your [ __ ] okay there's an expert in the
French ah gross a lot outside that
mansion they had everybody in slow
motion and that black dude jumped like
ten feet in the air
I was going to kick him he's going war
flying through the [ __ ] air now you
gotta understand how sheltered I was as
a kid I don't even know who Bruce Lee
was I didn't know what kung-fu fighting
was and I didn't realize that TV shows
were ripping off you know Enter the
Dragon and all that [ __ ] that people
were flipping out about cuz I was just a
little kid so I saw that [ __ ] it was the
most unbelievable thing ever he fought
Bigfoot he fought a black Bruce Lee and
he fought the seven million dollar man
and he punched his [ __ ] face off and
tell me they just don't they don't make
it's impossible to compete now there's
just they've just done too many things
you know it's kind of like when you go
to write a movie script like
everything's been done and they act like
all these guys back in the 40s and 50s
were brilliant it's like [ __ ] yo there
was only like five movies were ever made
how hard was it to be brilliant back
then
it's like inventing [ __ ] neat in the
1800s look it's a coat hanger you can
hang your coat on it holy [ __ ] let's put
his name in the history books everyone
can [ __ ] remember this for the rest
of the time I don't even know what you
could invent you know is great it's
still inventing simple [ __ ] is that
Billy Mays guy you know that bear did
[ __ ] every night he just starts sob
Billy Mays hi Billy Mays here for the
Jupiter Jack the most convenient
hands-free device for any cell phone
guaranteed that dude he doesn't even
invent this [ __ ] I think he invented
like three things and then he's just got
a sweatshop of like smart [ __ ] kids
from Thailand
and he just comes walking in I keep bar
to myself on the iron come up with some
[ __ ] then like three weeks later he's on
TV I'm Billy Mays are you tired of
burning the hair off your forearm when
you're ironing your button-down cuz your
third marriage didn't work out and you
still have to date in your 50s
introducing the [ __ ] thing you stick
in front of the iron that doesn't burn
your forearm but still irons the [ __ ]
shirt um anyways oh let me get let me
get back to this thing sorry that's like
that there you go I wanted to stand up
mo give you some [ __ ] laughs okay
and is left eye but this is I do it's
like a zoom lens on a camera a zoom lens
amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
like a boss so anybody watch 60 minutes
this past week they did a they did this
feature the feature on mountain lions
and now California is the only state
that has mountain lions just walking
around Los Angeles and its suburbs are
home to 19 million people
the only mega city in the world where
mountain lions also known as cougars and
Pumas live side-by-side with humans for
13 years the National Park Service has
been studying the animal I I'm gonna
[ __ ] this up in a park I guess maybe the
size of like Griffith Park or Runyon
Canyon or whatever those ones are out
and uh out in the valley p22 he wanders
the hills of Griffith Park a small
enclave in Los Angeles frequented by
hikers and visitors to the parks famed
observatory I guess they have these
[ __ ] things and so anyways I was
watching it because a few of the places
is where I hike with my dog and this
thing has intermittently this does this
group of [ __ ] mountain lions has been
around there but fortunately they try to
avoid you I guess a trail camera caught
this one a stone's throw from the
rooftops of suburbia
and these animals do their best to you
know stay elusive and away from us at
least during the day if then I [ __ ]
hungry but they showed this [ __ ]
these people this mountain lion right
okay they were having some work done so
they had somebody going underneath the
house into the crawlspace of their house
and they all ran up against this park
and the guy went down there and he
immediately came back up and he was
[ __ ] like white as a ghost and they
were like Donda is you know [ __ ]
white people trying to speak Spanish
right Oh a is it French I don't know and
a guy comes out of the [ __ ] hole was
like yeah man I [ __ ] there's a mount
lying down there
I just came faced and I get out of here
you sure are you staff and they were
like he's like yeah it's [ __ ] down
there and and so anyways they interview
this [ __ ] la couple and they had the
quintessential [ __ ] la couple
mountain line in your house bro
and so he said you know the mouse the
face I know I came out I with it any
music terrify you know what I mean
he looks like the leading man of a
b-movie right she's got like bleach
blonde hair she's wearing fuck-me pumps
she's on 60 minutes wearing fuck-me
pumps it's [ __ ] hilarious walking
around done up to the nines and I
actually it was pretty cool I was trying
to figure out where the house was I
google mapped it and I think I was able
to find it but [ __ ] this state is so
[ __ ] insane with the droughts the
fires the rattlesnakes the coyotes the
mountain lions you know and everybody's
in this place is so phony and so plastic
well you know it can get that can all go
away pretty damn quick with the wildlife
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast from
Monday August 2nd 2010 oh my god Martha
can you believe it
it's already August could you believe it
Martha actually I can't Karen because it
was just July in my entire life
August has come after July so yes I can
believe that it's August 2nd why do you
have to do that do what that you know
why can't you just you know have
frivolous conversation why do you have
to be why do you have to be such a god
no I'm sorry well that's what's your big
um anyway oh gee oh Jesus
oh my god what the [ __ ] did I do last
night I was gonna do the podcast last
night that was the plan boys and girls
ladies and gentlemen children of all
ages I was gonna do the podcast last
night I was gonna upload this
[ __ ] midnight my time you know
for all my friends out there and the
[ __ ] Great Britain out there in
Ireland and Iceland you know that'd be
like 8 o'clock in the morning for you
right you get up you people in Iceland
throwing down some hay for your [ __ ]
yaks taking out your pan flute skipping
around looking for the gold who's know
what you do out there yeah well that's
what I think you'd do coz I took
geography in America so you know what's
up Holland House you windmills
now you're clicking your [ __ ] wooden
shoes together that's my version that's
my version of Holland they don't have
cell phones out there cell phones it's
still using pitchforks to get their
point across um that didn't even make
sense but what it what did I do instead
you know this is the classic life of the
loser all right and if you are a loser
not saying you are okay hypothetically
if you are a loser
you're gonna recognize
this pattern okay and this is the
pattern of the loser will see the loser
knows what he or she is supposed to do
and then and then you never do it and
that is a pattern of a loser all right
did that make any [ __ ] sense it
started like I was gonna make this huge
[ __ ] point and then my headache
really just kicked in there but let's
let's try it let's try to put the wheels
back on the card here alright just like
those people out there in Finland right
now and all the people down and [ __ ]
Australia wrestling those poisonous
snakes as the Aborigines [ __ ] sit
there with that that white goddamn tooth
sticking through their nose you know
that shark tooth that Greg Brady had
around his [ __ ] neck when he was
gonna be the next Johnny Bravo huh just
sitting there [ __ ] staring at me
there Aborigine man you think I need
that [ __ ] you think you think I'm the
one who kicked you off your [ __ ] land
I'm a goddamn indentured servant to the
[ __ ] banks they're half-naked
Aborigine dude alright so stop [ __ ]
staring at me
alright with your thong you're [ __ ]
sad face alright I didn't create
plastics I'm just dealing with it why
don't you show me how to [ __ ] join
whatever it is you're thinking about
rather than [ __ ] judging me and by
the way could you help me with this
[ __ ] snake over here um anyways this
is what the loser does yeah I was gonna
I was I was gonna do X Y and C but
instead I did [ __ ] de and F [ __ ]
idiot instead of me when the goddamn
podcast I went out and I drank last
night oh jeez I had two whiskey's and
two Miller highlights why did I have
Miller High Life
you know what cuz the bottle looked good
I like the way the bottle look it's one
of those nights there's a shiny looking
bottle I like that I'm gonna have that
I'm gonna block out those [ __ ]
Miller High Life commercials I hated
those commercials that [ __ ] plumber
with his greasy fingers picking up that
deviled egg it's like are you trying to
stood Budweiser right these [ __ ] ads
all right this is just anger just a
frustration at myself I don't know why I
did the things I did last night I shot
pool you know like I'm [ __ ] Willie
Mosconi you know that's it you know as a
man you just walk up to a pool table
even though you know you suck and you're
just thinking you know seven Ball corner
pocket Shh it's gonna [ __ ] go right
in and never goes in you know just like
your life you think it's on target you
think it's heading right towards you
wait where you want it to go and BAM
bounces off the [ __ ] wall and next
thing you know it's all the way on the
other side of the [ __ ] table this is
ridiculous I shouldn't be doing this
right now I resent I'm resenting I'm
blaming you guys I'm [ __ ] blaming you
sitting in your goddamn cubicles what do
you think about that what do you do you
can't [ __ ] do anything about it what
do you do you're gonna send me [ __ ]
emails complaining yeah well I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] I mean had
breakfast Jeff sitting here my pajamas
doing that thing when you hungover you
know we just sort of rub your feet
together trying to give yourself some
sort of soothing feelings on the other
end of your body because your [ __ ]
head is throbbing so much well maybe I
could offset the headache with a
soothing feeling between my foot ease
and of course it's not working
oh [ __ ] Jesus Christ two whiskey's and
two bears I feel like I [ __ ] I don't
know like I don't know what like I had a
fight in the parking lot and I lost the
last thing I remember was somebody
grabbing my big ears and bouncing my
head off the asphalt as I'm going all
right all right you won you won and then
you just slip off into a dream you know
it's weird I woke up whenever I wake up
hungover you know one of the first
things I do is I just start cursing out
the woman in my life
you know this is my remedy for getting
over
a hangover you know you wake up and you
see them you know and you try to get the
[ __ ] you know the goddamn cement out
of your eyes you're trying to open them
up and of course cuz you're hungover and
you want to be alone the vibe you're
putting out is you want to be alone what
happens you create you attract what you
[ __ ] fear not only another human
being right in your goddamn face it's
got to be a female okay and God knows
can they ever stop running their yaps
it's like even when they don't have
something to say they're gonna [ __ ]
talk because as much as they talk a good
game
I'm an independent woman and I got my
money [ __ ] all that [ __ ] at the
end of the day all these broads are
afraid of the same thing they're afraid
of silence that's what it is you know
that when you watch one of those goddamn
shows or in my life you walk by and your
girls watching one of those goddamn
shows and why am i bring my voice down
like she's still in the apartment she
isn't but you know what is why bring my
voice down here this is me they're
talking about the loominatee or I'm
talking about these [ __ ] [ __ ] this
is all hangover talk here so I'll [ __ ]
all you guys if you're taking this
seriously
all right rule number one or is it
number two at this point you don't
[ __ ] take the podcast seriously okay
all you girls out there you get your
panties in a bunch because that's life
sweetheart and life isn't fair why don't
you go listen to one of those [ __ ]
2012 art cast with the [ __ ] broad
over there running her goddamn yet
between a cleavage huh
why don't you go do that sister man with
your tampons in your purse just in case
whoo I am in a mood um yeah so I'm
sitting there and I got [ __ ] they're
afraid of silence stay on target
are there afraid of silence and that's
why they talk about nothing oh that's
what I was trying to say you walk by the
TV and your girlfriend's sitting there
right she you know sitting there you
know on the couch riding the couch
sidesaddle
you know they sit leaned up against the
arm with their legs to the side rubbing
their footies together that are peeking
out of the Afghan what I like this show
you watch your shows do I say anything
when you're watching your shows I don't
so why didn't you extend shut up so you
know you walk by the [ __ ] TV you walk
by the goddamn TV and what and what is
it what is on the TV you know what I
don't even remember I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about
oh yeah they're just running their yaps
all day I got it here we go I'm hooked
backed up to it there we go that was a
little awkwardness there like you ever
see when I when a jet tries to refuel in
mid-flight you know and that shark dick
is hanging down I know what a shark dick
looks like what do think about that is
that scandalous enough to get on TMZ at
my low level of notoriety I do I was
watching this [ __ ] nature show and
these [ __ ] creepy humans cuz that's
what we are pull this great white shark
out of the [ __ ] sea and the Sharks
laying there like I can't [ __ ]
breathe over here right and they got
this little garden hose going into his
mouth and it's seeing the sharks looking
like really this is the same as it isn't
[ __ ] hailing a mouthful of ocean your
little [ __ ] True Value Hardware
garden hose that you got my [ __ ]
mouth what are they doing
get away from my dick please and they
literally reach down and between a
couple of Falls he pull out this shark
[ __ ] which amazingly enough looks just
like the [ __ ] that that tube that
they refuel in the air for with or
whatever the [ __ ] preposition is that
a preposition I don't [ __ ] know
trying to complete a sentence over here
and that's what it looks like all right
there you go that portion was dedicated
to all our troops over there in
Afghanistan and in Tuscaloosa um you
know he's a weird thing I was sitting in
the airport the other day I'm gonna get
back to the Broads I'm gonna give them a
break right now okay I I tried I tried
to knock him out in that round and now
I'm [ __ ] winded I'm taking a round off
his they're starting to score points I'm
just giving him I'm just giving him hope
taking a round off but I'm coming out
with the next one I'm footing a glove in
their face like Larry Holmes and I'm
coming with the overhand right my
favorite [ __ ] thing in boxing um oh
god what was I just talking about I was
talking about shark dicks after shark
dicks oh I know I'm in the airport all
right this is just gonna be all momentum
I'm gonna just try to not stop talking
for 50 minutes because when I stop
talking the throbbing in my head is
actually audible all right slow it down
now let's take it down a little bit
little [ __ ] some [ __ ] smooth jazz
here all right so I'm sitting in the
[ __ ] Airport this was an awkward
thing right all these troops came
walking by and these people
spontaneously started to applaud you
know and I didn't know what to do do I
join in it just didn't seem right but
then you don't want to not [ __ ] show
your appreciation but applause just
seems weird it just seemed weird and I
was trying to put myself in their
[ __ ] position like you know you just
came out of Fallujah did what you had to
do over there and then you get [ __ ]
too however it works next thing you know
you're on JetBlue and you land at an
airport and there's a soccer mom oh good
game good game no I don't know what to
do definitely appreciate it but so
that's for the troops out there do you
want applause in the airport or is it
[ __ ] weird you know cuz we don't want
to do that [ __ ] that happened to the
troops when they came back from Vietnam
and all those [ __ ] hippies were like
hey man that wasn't cool when you burned
down that dudes Hut me and we don't want
to do that but I don't want to have an
overcorrection you know well you like
that
[Music]
is that [ __ ] silently played oh I'm
trying to think of like college football
songs you know here come the troops but
have adapt bump Bama nanana in order let
it go yet
Dadda Dadda Dadda you don't want to go
like to high energy there's got to be a
happy medium between saying there being
like all the leaves are brown and then
sitting there you know applauding like
somebody just sank a putt it just didn't
seem right all right so anyway see walk
by the TV and there's the and the Broads
always they're always talking about how
much more I guess how much what better
communicators females are which I've
probably proven in the last [ __ ] 14
minutes of this podcast you know if a
woman actually says 20,000 more words a
day than a guy does do you realize that
yet do you think I didn't notice I
thought it was 40,000 more okay and let
me tell you something they're [ __ ]
sinkhole wait just because you say in
more words doesn't mean you're saying
anything all right
you basically filibuster your way
through silence with your girlfriend
because both of you are sitting there
afraid that if you stop talking you're
gonna hear the sound of your boobs
sagging all right oh yeah well that's
what I think it is in my own [ __ ]
ignorance all right let's get on with
the podcast here people I'm sorry I had
to I had to do a little cardio there
just to get myself through the first 15
minutes you know now I can [ __ ] chill
so I woke up hungover today obviously
and I'm attacking the broads because I'm
hungover and now for the most part I
don't like I like to look at him I like
to come over and stick my dick in them
you know but after that it's like why
don't you get out in the kitchen and
make me one of them [ __ ] belong the
sandwiches once you just [ __ ] love to
be that guy you know just find some
little
[ __ ] Mouse of a woman to live with
just blame your entire afternoon on her
where the [ __ ] is a [ __ ] room up well
you had it last what the [ __ ] did you
say I I guess it was my fault this is
terrible this isn't even comedy anymore
this is just mean so I woke up this
morning hungover as I've mentioned 98
times and for some reason I woke up and
uh this song was in my head I just woke
up but this was the song it was in my
head right here hungover off my ass and
all of a sudden I just hear Elvis
she will shake me you [ __ ] aah whoo
that's one of the great [ __ ] songs by
Elvis Presley and when you really listen
to the lyrics it's he's a [ __ ] psycho
he's stalking this broad hot in the
kitchen hot in the hole are you gonna do
your headache good at all cuz once I get
you in the kitchen kitchen and the
kisses starts a team of wild horses
couldn't pull us apart
he's singing about rape everybody but he
gets that oh ho ho and it's unit just
smooths it all out and that's why he was
the king only the King can make rape
seem like it's it's the right thing to
do
for both parties let's just be clear on
that for both parties all right let's
get on with the podcast okay I I [ __ ]
love that song I really do and I was
working the Orleans and Casino with Tom
pop and the marriage reps Tom papa
I was coming out on stage like that and
I have a second I felt like a million
bucks for half a [ __ ] second can you
believe it's August um all right so
let's get on with the podcast last week
ladies and gentlemen I had the pleasure
of performing on the David Letterman
Show and most of you went out you
watched it and you all sent me wonderful
emails about it and I would read you the
wonderful emails but they're not funny
but you are in luck you know what ones
are funny the ones where people did not
like my performance so let's read a
couple of those shall we all right now
my [ __ ] nose is running okay never
had the balls never had the balls to
mess with that [ __ ] okay this is uh this
is somebody and as always for those of
you whenever I read my hate mail both of
these the two hate mail emails that I
would be reading this morning obviously
nice
like right now like a teacher teaching a
really boring class you know that you're
in your you know first class of that
semester right you finally got yourself
a little bit of poontang you're happy
you're floating around everything's
gonna be great you're thinking okay
let's see how my teachers are gonna be
and then that douche comes out
welcome to meteorology in the media
my name is mr. [ __ ] face and mr. [ __ ]
face were me in third grade I'm sorry
I'm hungover I couldn't come up with my
name is mr. McGillicuddy no of course
the next three months we are going to be
delving into the wonderful world of
meteorology in the media you will be
required to write 227 page papers on
serious clouds in the Dakotas
okay so serious clouds were first
discovered it was 1605 an whether they
laugh and they picks up the [ __ ]
marker he's writing across that [ __ ]
board so they're mocking lines have yet
the third and at first before Sir Marcus
was happily at the third they thought
cirrus clouds we're actually the God's
sake bet your wife was a [ __ ] I get
nothing was the breathing annoying it
was supposed to be alright let's read
the hate mail here so what happens with
all of all of my hate mail is when
people don't like my act is you can't
just write me evidently and just say
that you don't like my act you don't
appreciate what it is that I doing the
stage what you have to do first is you
have to establish what an incredible
sense of [ __ ] humor you have and how
open you are to all different forms of
humor you know it's that classic thing
like those douche bags on YouTube
Obama's a [ __ ] idiot and I'm a
Democrat
right so then we can be like wow this
guy is left and even he doesn't like
this lefty guy so this is what they do
all right so here so these both these
emails follow to a goddamn [ __ ] teeth
to the [ __ ] U and B um they
follow it here it they follow that
pattern bill just read the [ __ ] thing
okay
here we go all right hi there this one
starts starts off nice enough hi there
I've been a fan for a while you seem to
have a unique take on things look at
this huh
Pat me on the head let me sniff her hand
making me nice and [ __ ] relaxed
I loved your bit about the muffins and
the mass vehicular murder so there you
go she just showed how it just her sense
of humor spans the globe whether I'm
attacking food or actually running over
human beings on the sidewalk she finds
it all funny though and here's the rub
though as a stay-at-home mom I now
completely despise you I did this bit
about being a stay-at-home mom what he
was she says the hardest part about
being a stay-at-home mom is being
respect is being disrespected by
everyone I now hope the worse for you
despite what funny acts you may think up
in the future you are a jerk and deserve
the worst that life has to offer I don't
[ __ ] it I don't I don't understand like
these this is the classic [ __ ] person
where everything is funny until it comes
around to some [ __ ] in her life and I
make some fun of some [ __ ] that she's
doing being a stay-at-home mom and now
all of a sudden she goes from being a
fan of mine so now I am a jerk and
deserve the worst that life has to offer
that's that's a [ __ ] hard courts that
you deserve the worst that life has to
offer so what I'm gonna get leprosy
and be constipated all at the same time
and [ __ ] survive a plane crash but
not in a good way you know anyways I
don't [ __ ] know really you're gonna
take it to that level so I wrote her
back I said sweetheart oprah winfrey
called your job the toughest job on the
planet
on national television and got an
applause break of approval
how much more respect do you need I
think that's a great point if I can step
outside the email break the [ __ ]
fourth wall is that what it is the third
wall I never knew what the [ __ ] it was
huh Oprah Winfrey's on TV saying you
have the toughest job on the planet and
everybody claps all right did she say
being a stand-up comedian is a toughest
job on the planet you think you know
what it's like to be [ __ ]
disrespected you apron wearing sheltered
son of a [ __ ] huh you want to talk
about being disrespected look at [ __ ]
comedians anytime they show a comedian
in a movie is it a Chris Rock level
comic it never is
it's the [ __ ] hack with the lampshade
on his head going Wacka Wacka
right then the [ __ ] comedian gets
shot in his gut during Scarface huh did
a [ __ ] stay-at-home mom gets shot in
the [ __ ] stomach with that mr. Potato
Head mask on her face during that show
no you know why cuz she was at home
taking care of the [ __ ] kids ah Jesus
Christ I'm just gonna read the rest this
email I didn't even [ __ ] make sense
it started off funny and then it just
went right off the rails like a Prius
that you can't [ __ ] stop um anyways
she says so I wrote I wrote how much
more respect do you need and then I said
meanwhile there are children working in
sweatshops would you rather be a
stay-at-home mom or an eight-year-old
sowing adidas together for 16 hours a
day I came up with another great example
that I wish I had used on TV how about
how about you work on one of those
[ __ ] oil rigs like those poor
bastards who work for BP then all of a
sudden out of nowhere the [ __ ] thing
explodes
standing on a metal structure in the
middle of the goddamn ocean and next
thing you know it blows up probably blew
out both your eardrums you deaf now and
you're on fire all right and your only
option is either burning to death or
jumping off of basically the equivalent
of the top of a brownstone trying to
enter the water without doing the
world's biggest flaming belly flop
right you land in the water second and
third-degree burns in saltwater
all right pus and blood is oozing into
the water and now all you can do is pray
to God that the Coast Guard gets there
before a sea of sharks eat you alive all
right you want to do that you want to
watch Bob the Builder for the 800th time
lighten up
and then I route oh and don't despise or
hope the worse for me that causes
premature aging hugs I know that was
kind of mean to say but you know what go
[ __ ] yourself all right here's another
one once again we have to establish
credibility at the top of the email are
you guys ready for the credibility to be
established Jesus Christ I know I am
here we go bill
I am never appalled or CAPITAL LETTERS
offended by comedy that I see in here
all capitals this sentence I have a
great sense of humor wow this is
unbelievable this is that amazing
podcast listeners this person is never
appalled or offended by comedy that she
sees or hears she has a great sense of
humor she has such a great sense of
humor people that she had to yell it at
me in emails all right so just no way
she had a problem with my act right
let's read the rest of the email however
oh jeez your appearance on the David
Letterman Show that I just watched just
put down women and motherhood to an
extent that is just downright
unbelievable dot dot dot now she's going
to yell again and tasteless
now she yells for the rest of this email
but I'm gonna spare you guys alright I'm
gonna read it in soothing tones but
she's screaming the entire time that's
what I'm guessing because it's all
capital letters
um this is what she says I challenge you
to be a single parent and raise a child
and work and attend college alone
without any help just in case you don't
know what being a single parent means
alright you have no idea how hard it
really is I am disgusted with your act
and will not ever buy any of your DVDs
etc for the first time in my life I am
disgusted with comedy your comedy that
is like oh she starts speaking like in
film noir now I'm discussing with this
comedy y'all comedy that is see ya 23
skidoo
alright your act touched on many topics
that you were disgraceful and very
unappealing I think she got so mad she
stopped writing sentences first of all
sweetheart I wasn't making fun of single
parents single parents I was making fun
of single parents nobody would laugh I
was talking about stay-at-home moms
alright you don't remember that line
hanging out all day making grilled
cheese sandwiches you're giving a puppet
show you dress like a dragon and then
some other adult comes home and gives
you money
you're like a big kid that's some other
adults coming home giving you money is
your [ __ ] husband you dumb broad do I
got a [ __ ] spell it out to you so I
just wrote her back I just said I wasn't
talking about single moms I was talking
about stay-at-home moms you weren't
listening listen I'm not gonna do this
show anymore if I have to put up with
this I'm just kidding I love these
[ __ ] hate mail things that's all I
got I got I got two too bad emails and
then I had one guy who wrote like a five
page dissertation on on the shirt I was
wearing under my suit or something like
and then I just went homophobic with him
I just wrote that's one of the gayest
emails I've ever received thanks for the
fashion advice and then he wrote back
trying to act as if I got a bunch of
emails from guys telling me to wear a
carnation in my front pocket or whatever
the [ __ ] he was saying and he wrote this
big long [ __ ] four-page email and
then I just hit him with come on sweetie
don't be like that and then it ended it
alright guy I got a lot of little weird
emails this week
somebody saw date night and said I need
to be more choosy when I pick my roles
which I thought was [ __ ] hilarious
like someone who has eight lines in a
movie is actually getting offers around
town we got to get this guy the way I'm
telling you the way he stands next to
other people talking in the film is
incredible he he is the best at it you
know I gotta be more choosy with
[ __ ] evidently because I wasn't
doing stand-up in the movie date night
like the role of my character was the
straight man and the Moore's the
straighter I played it the more
opportunity for the other person to be
funny in the scene that's your [ __ ]
job
you know and I did the job and I think
that wasn't the job that I was supposed
to do I would think that the director
mighty said something and just because
I'm a [ __ ] comedian doesn't mean I'm
gonna walk around you know with a
lampshade on my [ __ ] head I'd love to
be in a bad ass [ __ ] movie what do
you think I want to do you know you
think I want to be in Raising Arizona
part two actually I would but I'd also
like to be in they can never make a
movie as good as a Goodfellas I'd love
to do some [ __ ] like that play a [ __ ]
psycho put the lotion in the bucket what
wouldn't want to do that [ __ ] all right
you dumb [ __ ] I I don't need to be more
choosy about my roles I need to take
anything anybody gives me you know
[ __ ] shot that movie a year ago I
haven't done another one is that choosy
enough for you it's nothing I'm guns not
like I'm not trying alright
let's plow ahead here let's get on with
what else do we got going on oh by the
way I want to thank everybody seriously
I'm just [ __ ] around there with the
letterman stuff I had an unbelievably
great time and that was my best
Letterman if I do say so myself
I finally figured out the pacing that I
have to go on TV and what I always used
to try to do is I used to try to go
comedy club speed but TV audiences for
some reason laugh and clap a lot more
and then I what I would try to do was
plow through the applause and get the
tag of the joke in there and I don't
know it's like a whole different animal
you got to figure out what do you do
when they're applauding you know why did
the chicken cross the road to get the
other side maybe that's why I didn't
applaud when the troops came by because
I thought that they would feel as
awkward as I do when you're just
standing there going okay thank you yes
I know that was the greatest joke in the
history of the world
I am tremendous where do you get a load
of this one
all right let's read some let's read
some much oh and by the way later on
that night in celebration I had the most
ridiculous [ __ ] weekend that an adult
can have and part of most of his because
you know I chose what I wanted to do in
life was exactly what I wanted to do and
secondly I'm not married and I don't
have any [ __ ] kids so I don't have
any responsibility hence I I get to live
the life of a gay guy
let me notice how happy [ __ ] gay men
are you know why that is is because they
got the [ __ ] double whammy they're a
[ __ ] man so they can earn way more an
hour than the [ __ ] broads over there
and then they don't have any goddamn
kids so once you get around 40 if you've
done grading your your career you have
all this disposable income you know and
the only way
to kill the voices in your head that you
should have had a [ __ ] kid by now is
to go out and do frivolous [ __ ] to
fill up the free time and that's what
I've been doing
so I actually this weekend one of the
things I got to do this past weekend is
so [ __ ] unbelievable I can't even
tell you how it even went down but I did
take video of it and if you want to
watch the video you can only go one
place everybody and that's the MM
podcast.com huh you like that look at
that an exclusive Monday morning podcast
video that will only be shown on the MM
podcast.com of course until some
douchebag takes it and puts it up on
YouTube so go to the mm podcast comp and
watch a video of something that I got to
do and I don't even I can't even begin
to tell you how that whole [ __ ] thing
went down and how I got to do it but uh
was one of the great things I got to do
in life so I got to do that which I
won't be telling you because I'm trying
to become a smarter businessman here
alright
the only way you should hit pause right
now go to the mmm podcast right now if
you're not following along anyways um I
got to do that unbelievable activity and
then what did i do i did Letterman on
Monday and then Monday night I went down
to the bitter end and I watched that
[ __ ] amazing guy Oz Noi miss
guitarist if you ever get a chance if
you ever in New York one Monday a night
this guy oz night goes down and he I
don't know I can't even describe what
the [ __ ] it is he does very very unique
guitarist and he I don't need you gotta
see him live you have to [ __ ] see him
live his YouTube videos do not do him
justice you got to go down and see him
live and and he's always playing with
these top-notch musicians he had will
Lee from the letterman band was there
Steve Ferrone II from the average white
band actually went out and got a [ __ ]
picture with him and [ __ ] from the
average white band and now Tom Petty and
he's played with a zillion other
people one of my drumming heroes got to
meet him that [ __ ] night and the guy
on keyboards is one of the original guys
from the E Street Band but I'm not into
the E Street Band but this guy was the
[ __ ] and I just watched these [ __ ]
unbelievable musicians and sat in the
crowd these guys were so [ __ ] good
that actually had the comforting thought
that you know what robots will never
take over fully robots will never fully
[ __ ] take over because they'll never
be able to do what I just [ __ ] saw I
mean when you're gonna write a program
for passion god knows some [ __ ]
egghead with no passion
he's probably figuring that [ __ ] out
figure out how to make a robot sweat
well it plays [ __ ] guitar
[Laughter]
that'll be it'll be the big [ __ ]
breakthrough that's why drum machines
never fully took over cuz it's just
somebody programming the [ __ ] you know
it's not a human being playing it right
is that what I don't know I'm too
[ __ ] hungover to actually have a
[ __ ] a [ __ ] touching moment here
in the podcast alright a couple weeks
ago I told you guys how to dump how to
get out of a [ __ ] relationship
alright
and if you ever want to learn how to not
get into a relationship go download
Andrew Dice clays live album at
Dangerfield that they the day the
laughter died and one of my favorite
bits of all time that he does is I think
it's called
how to how to not get into a
relationship so if you don't want to
deal with how to get out of a
relationship listen to Dice clays bit on
how to not get into into a relationship
and but then if you [ __ ] up and you get
into what listen to my podcast from a
couple of weeks ago and I'll give you
the blueprint on how to get out alright
so anyway so this brought up the whole
getting dumped and people have been
sending me emails about getting dumped
or breaking up and the awkwardness and
all that type of [ __ ] he's some great
stories here's one for you getting
dumped hey Bill I was listening to last
week and wanted to tell you about the
worst way I was dumped
when I was in high school I had a friend
who was a girl and I was in love with
her in a pathetic never getting laid way
while she was banging half the football
team ah dude that's like that movie last
last American virgin right then I
already use that reference on the
podcast I don't give a [ __ ] I'm hungover
anyways after high school graduate
graduation we started dating even though
we went to different colleges seven
hours apart over file yeah I love how
she starts dating you then because the
football team left her and went to 47
different colleges so she just needed a
dick to ride over fall break I went to
visit her and stayed at her place for
the weekend on the last night at
midnight she told me she was seeing
someone else and then expected me to
stay at her house that night
oh what a [ __ ] umm I got up and packed
my [ __ ] and as I was about to leave I
did my best Brando impression to let her
know how she how she [ __ ] up and as I
started to go out the door after making
my dramatic statement she said don't you
need your keys oh this poor bastard he
goes I forgot my keys on the table all
the way across the room so I had to walk
all the way across back the room back
across the room in shame to grab my keys
and then drove seven hours back to
college in the middle of in the middle
of the night dude let me tell you
something you got you got half a victory
there because you did leave
you know and you did you had the ability
to walk all the way across the room to
get your keys and at no point during
that long [ __ ] walk did you break
down in tears you didn't all right
don't you need your keys huh oh that's
[ __ ] brutal that's like that's like
mean
yeah because you know what she thought I
guess that you were gonna stay there for
the night so I guess she went mean there
don't you need your keys
obviously you need your keys if she was
trying to let you down easy wouldn't she
be like um you forgot your keys here and
just would have the decency to look down
at the floor don't you need your keys
dad this is what I want to know from you
on that seven hours drive back how many
different snappy comebacks did you come
with four don't you need your keys I bet
you was so [ __ ] distraught they didn't
even make sense don't you need your keys
don't you need your [ __ ] alright that
doesn't even make sense but you know
it's something you'd say ah you poor
bastard whatever you know what the good
news is she probably has three kids
right now her body's looking like she's
standing in a funhouse mirror and she
probably has some sort of [ __ ] STD so
you know there you go sir it all worked
out in the end didn't it alright uh bad
covers this is from back in the day
we're talking about when when an artist
comes around like a lady gaga
you know when she comes around and she
wraps herself in toilet paper and holds
a [ __ ] dildo and everybody's like
she's thinking of fashions day but she's
shocking middle America holding like a
black baby while playing chess is there
anything worse than that
paint-by-numbers shock you know and then
then the [ __ ] douchebags who cover it
just stand right in line she's pushing
boundaries she's rejecting what it is to
be a woman Oh God shut up she's wearing
a silly outfit is that what she's doing
and has a fan blowing on her [ __ ]
hanging off her belt buckle and then I'm
supposed to sit there and be like I
can't even process this this is
cutting-edge art
hey what is she really doing we read
about in my poker face poker face
oh my god I can't handle it this is like
when Jimi Hendrix came out no it isn't
this is like when Cindy Lauper came up
she braided half her [ __ ] head right
and danced down the street with their
[ __ ] shoulders going up and down
yelling at captain Lou albano it's it's
kind of on that level
remember when Cindy Lauper did that [ __ ]
and then she didn't do anything and next
thing you know she's on she's on that
[ __ ] who wants to be a CEO getting
fired by that guy who I don't even think
has any money or any Donald Trump fans
out there I don't think that guy is rich
I really don't I don't I don't buy it
if this guy is such if he's so [ __ ]
rich and has all these goddamn
businesses how does he have time to do a
reality show and in critique who's
better at running a lemonade stand Cyndi
Lauper or Bret Michaels is is that what
it what a [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever the
hell he is what do you call a guy like
that he's he's a conglomerate a media
conglomerate what the [ __ ] is he called
hey I can't think of the word I'm too
[ __ ] hungover
it's not like one of those aunjanue
named Stan I know that's not that what I
know what that that's not what it is a
Janu means you're a you're a
good-looking Gor Gor good-looking [ __ ]
who's someday my brain is so [ __ ] right
now I just combined good-looking in
[ __ ] and like she's a good she's a Gore
Al Gore Al Gore who is a bitchier
[ __ ] body Al Gore or [ __ ] Bill
Clinton both of them they're big mother
and hips
sashay around the White House with their
[ __ ] suits on eating Stoffer [ __ ]
pies I am so off the track right now
we're talking about bad covers
no this is this is this is what I really
believe about Donald Trump for all his
[ __ ] Trump water
Trump Tower Trump casino Trump
helicopter trumped toenail clippers I I
don't think that that guy if you gave
him [ __ ] if you gave him 12 hours I
don't think that he could come up with
more than 6,500 bucks in cash I think
he's just completely leveraged out but
his projects are so big he's like the
bank's like he he's too big to fail not
Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] am I talking
about where the hell am i let's get back
to bad covers all right bad covers
here's one for you
Madonna when she did American Pie yeah
that song kind of sucked to begin with
and then just in case you didn't realize
it sucked Madonna came in and proved it
yes this song did suck you know even if
you completely switch it up and put that
club beat underneath it it's still gonna
[ __ ] suck mouth Jesus I'm just running
out of momentum you know did I really
just do a Lady gaga impression I'll [ __ ]
you you enjoyed it you enjoyed it you
know you do a podcast hungover I want to
see how good you do yeah I didn't think
so
I didn't [ __ ] think so here's your
YouTube videos for the week we're just
blowing through the topics here YouTube
videos for the week
pug pugs sings Batman theme look that
one up
alright pug as in the dog pee ug pug as
opposed to a Gore pug sings Batman theme
drunk-ass knockout a lot of this shit's
gonna have to do with alcohol this week
wasted guy at Coachella Coachella is co
CH e el LA and here's one for you do
something difficult and you know what I
actually forgot the most [ __ ] up one
of the week I have to just bear with me
here
I have my the microphone laying on my
chest right now I want to say somebody
used to do that didn't like one of those
those guys late at night when they're
trying to sell your [ __ ] before they
came up with the Janet Jackson
McDonald's drive-thru headset didn't
they have like that hands-free device
where the microphone just dangled from
your neck I want to say that they had
that all the other guys that's a movie
coming out that the other guys I
actually had I had an audition for that
movie and I got all the way down to the
part with a guy who got the part was
[ __ ] yeah I think he went in before
me and killed it so now when I see that
movie I was like I look so [ __ ] funny
I could have been in there with eight
lines god dammit
all right the [ __ ] all right what's
the name of this video woman finds man
in bed something like that okay women
woman wakes up to find intruder in her
bed you got to see this one it's so
[ __ ] up I don't even know if it's real
it looks like a [ __ ] in living color
sketch all right overrated underrated
for this week and the overrated
underrated this week you guys really
took it to another level here this is
[ __ ] phenomenal all right underrated
first kid in your junior high that
admitted to jerking off that might be
one of my favorite under a turds of
all-time
what a [ __ ] champ that kid was you
know you know some people are still
trying to find themselves at 35 or
possibly 42 like myself that kid knew
who the [ __ ] he was in junior high
hey jerking off I do it [ __ ] feels
good I'll [ __ ] rub one out in next
class I like to teach her she's doing
something for me what I'm the last guy
in the and in the [ __ ] row just don't
turn around you'll be fine
number two whoever commented that Roger
Ebert now looks like one of the Muppets
from the land of confusion video Jesus
Christ on a side note that is one of the
his videos ever yeah man poor Roger
Ebert Jesus Christ you know what I mean
how ironic is that that he spent his
life criticizing people and then he gets
[ __ ] mouth cancer you know and he's
still criticizing [ __ ] he's like he's
like the goddamn a terminator um Jesus
Christ and if that's true what the [ __ ]
am I gonna get the [ __ ] gonna happen
to me all this [ __ ] that I spew um
number three Leopold butters Scotch next
- Cartman the best character on South
Park I hope I said the dude's name right
I love South Park I really love it and
I'm actually I'm gonna uh I'm starting
to watch the boondocks cuz everybody
told me that's the [ __ ] so watch it with
me and let's watch a quality show
together what do you say people anybody
else watching Breaking Bad I can't
believe I've been watching it for three
[ __ ] seasons and I haven't I haven't
haven't really talked about it I [ __ ]
love it
it's a goddamn it's a great show but
I've yet to get into that advertising
mad mad mad Men Mad Money the [ __ ] is it
I don't know everybody walks around
smoking uh-uh I heard it's great and
everybody on that shows dressed in suits
which I like number four underrated this
is another great one this is a new this
is this is this person's first
contribution to the podcast and I think
this person should be a staff writer
here's another [ __ ] gem number for
station wagons in the 80s with the rear
seats facing out the back window
kids have everything today but they
missed out on that one do you know my
parents had an 83 Caprice Classic maroon
with the fake wood going down the side
top of the line the wire wheels cloth
maroon [ __ ] interior we drove all the
way out to Chicago one time all the way
out to Chicago I was in the middle
couple my siblings were sitting in the
back and I was jealous that they got to
sit you know seeing what we just [ __ ]
saw and then my parents
that in the front and that bench seat
that blocked the AC and they wouldn't
let us put the windows down my [ __ ]
dad would sit there with his hands in
front of the you know his hands on the
vent like an inch away from the vent
failing the AC coming out you know
completely [ __ ] selfish and well they
can we turn it on we can you put the
windows down like now we got the AC on
yeah well the big cloth bench seat is
[ __ ] blocking it and we just sat
there looking at farmland whizzing by my
brothers actually got to stick their
heads out the window in the back you
know like a couple of [ __ ] mutts
and I sat there in the middle just had
to sit there taking it all right number
five underrated kids in the hall
absolutely when people bring up the
greatest sketch shows of all time you
know they'll say mr. show they'll say
Dave Chappelle and the people in the
know also say kids in the hall and I'd
have to definitely go with that all
right
overrated humping in the shower
abso-fucking-lutely that's exciting when
you're in college you know the sensation
of water you know yeah hopping in the
showers weird then the water is hitting
her booty crack it starts making a weird
noise you know as the water shoots up
from her [ __ ] ass crack it's hitting
you in your lower jaw you know who can
concentrate number two bartenders that
claim to have created their own drink is
it ever good it's never [ __ ] good
overrated Bourbon Street I got to go
with yet that is overrated you [ __ ]
go down there it's a bunch of goddamn
tourists who can't hold their [ __ ]
alcohol and then there's a bunch of
goddamn wolves on the side streets
waiting to [ __ ] stick a knife in your
neck also overrated National Spelling
Bee contests are overrated
I don't know I don't know if I go I'd
actually like those ones and I think
it's great that those kids learn how to
[ __ ] spell it's something that I wish
I learned how to do and I root for I
want him to win the spelling bee and I
also want him to get laid before they're
um here's a random one go on Google Maps
and you know when you can hit satellite
and actually look down you know and
actually bring yourself down on the
street with that little man here's one
for you in the middle of France this is
what you want to look up here's the
address 8 ru e which means Street D u of
duck ta gradual do c te u r g ra ND j EA
n that was one word g grande y all which
means big jean five four zero zero zero
nancy na NC y i just realized how long
this is and now i can't stop i got to
give me the whole thing comma m e u r th
e you guys writing this down like Morse
code - ET - mo s e ll e and then
Lorraine France
lor Rai and e all right
google map that hit the satellite bring
the little man down on the street and
tell me what the [ __ ] that is on that
porch tell me that's not a [ __ ] alien
there's an alien on the porch and the
satellite cut the picture of it
I don't know who knows it's probably a
goddamn beehive that was a long [ __ ]
way to go but I like it I think that has
a lot to do it's a good theme for this
podcast you know for a hungover son of a
[ __ ] with nothing in his penis in his
stomach other than the two slices of
pizza that I ate at 1:00 in the morning
la pizza by the way so you know it was
good you know something I just realized
I feel like I haven't said anything
funny in the last 20 minutes how long
ago was that clinton-gore with their
[ __ ] bodies sachet and around the
White House I know that that was funny
the sound of their milk-white hips
hitting that [ __ ] suit material
[Laughter]
nationwide health care
he's walking around the Oval Office both
of them yeah you know something I'm
gonna I'm gonna vote them that in my
lifetime the two bitchiest that's the
bitchiest tandem that has ever ever been
in the White House you know what I mean
I'll tell you right now I I didn't vote
for well actually 96 actually 96 I did
vote for Clinton but after that I've
just gone rogue
because then Clinton just turned out to
be the same [ __ ] dude
that that other guy the angry guy with
the pen Bob Dole right yeah that you did
the same [ __ ] they all do the same [ __ ]
oh you [ __ ] morons who voted for
Obama and now you're surprised can you
believe he's pretty much doing what
McCain would have done and I'm not
talking about the taxes [ __ ] I'm talking
about the Afghans yeah no [ __ ] I
don't even know what I'm talking about
but I'm sick all you douche bags
bitching about all the taxes do you
really think you're gonna have to
[ __ ] Wars and at some point when all
the rich people get up from the table
after they dig [ __ ] chew and screw
and when you did that you walked in with
your buddies and you ordered a big
[ __ ] meal and when the waitress went
up to bar you all ran out the door and
you jumped into your [ __ ] AMC Gremlin
and drove away laughing laughing your
ass off and that poor broad had to pay
for it do you know that there's a place
in Norwood Massachusetts called the Cafe
Venice and I did that 20 years ago and I
still feel guilty about it I went in
there and I'm not gonna name names but
it was a bunch of names there's too many
names to name and we stood up and we
were gonna pay and we and the waitress
was just not there and we just waited
and waited and waited and waited and I'm
like where the [ __ ] is she and then
there was that tension and there was
somebody there was just weird laughs and
somebody out of the group walked out the
door and then there was that panic oh my
god it was like that musical chair game
you didn't want to be the last one
standing well
musics playing playing cuz then you got
to pay for the check and then we all
just [ __ ] just burst it out the door
and I remember cuz it was really dark in
the cafe Venice I don't know if it even
exists anymore and then we went out into
the sunlight couldn't [ __ ] see [ __ ]
just running towards something that
looked like the shape of our car just
that young [ __ ] energy that you had
we could actually be stuff with food and
still run and laugh and still get away
you know and we just got in the car and
just laughed our asses off the whole way
and I immediately afterwards I felt
guilty because I knew that she would
have to pay for it and this is how young
I was I actually ordered a large milk
with my meal I was like 18 or 19 and I
was one of those guys who just never
stopped drinking milk I didn't stop
drinking milk until I was like I don't
know somewhere in my [ __ ] late 20s I
used to drink I loved it I loved a nice
cold glass of [ __ ] milk and I had it
with like every meal and it was you know
my first time at 18 we're all of a
sudden you not realizing you're hanging
out with adults I just graduated high
school and everybody's ordering and they
go yeah and let me get let me get uh you
know some [ __ ] rigatoni with the
fault of meat sauce over there and I'll
get a [ __ ] Coke in a while every
order and cokes a beer and blah blah
blah I was like I don't have the
spaghetti and meatballs and I'll have a
large milk and that was this pause and
then the ball break and began and it
never [ __ ] ended for the rest of it
you know and whatever I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm saying what the [ __ ] am I
saying oh yeah yeah so they hit they we
got to [ __ ] wars for eight goddamn
years and then all the corporation's got
up from the table ran out to their
[ __ ] top-of-the-line bulletproof SUVs
and they drove off and yeah they left us
with the tab and all you guys think that
we're not gonna have to pay it back you
think the taxes aren't coming there [ __ ]
they're coming oh they're coming
there you go that was my [ __ ] what's
going on with the world now [ __ ] you go
[ __ ] yourself whatever I made it to an
hour I made another one that's all it is
that's all it is it's like The Drew
Carey Show the last nine seasons where
they're just going whatever it's
syndication money who gives a [ __ ] let's
just bring in some fat broad with crazy
makeup and have Dru yell at her
well people watch it great we'll all get
[ __ ] paid we're all gonna get [ __ ]
paid hey did anybody read that story in
that magazine I think was Esquire
magazine about that guy who [ __ ] went
on The Price is Right and like a card
counter he just feet broke the bank he
went both showcases in the 37 years or
whatever the shock The Price is Right
has been on the air no one has ever
guessed the exact amount of the showcase
that they bid on and this guy did it and
all you have to do was come within 50
bucks or a hundred bucks and you win
both showcases and this guy he [ __ ]
he nailed both he hit it right on the
head and to the point they thought he
was cheating because everybody was
winning that day and they can't figure
it out if it was him or if it was this
other guy in the audience who was
[ __ ] tipping people off because they
were giving away cars and I guess The
Price is Right has to pay for the prizes
so evidently Drew Carey didn't think
that the episode was gonna air so he was
kind of a dick when he said you won both
and then I guess they ended up [ __ ]
airing it during like a sweeps week so
he kind of looked like a dick but I
guess that price is right people were
not thrilled so there's this whole
article and he's saying the he's only
guilty of being an avid fan of the show
and the price is right [ __ ] up by they
would have reoccurring prices I'm
reoccurring prizes like they had some
sort of smoker on there one of those
eggs smokers you ever seen those [ __ ]
things and he knew the exact [ __ ]
price of it so when he was in
contestants row they were like the egg
smoker somebody was like 1,500 and he
goes you know and
you don't know the exact prices somebody
says 1500 you think it's about 1500 you
usually go 1501 or you say 1200 to try
to get the next you know 300 in your
favor he said like [ __ ] I'm gonna go
with 1478 and he nailed it first Fred
[ __ ] flam am I really gonna go through
the whole episode it's out there people
but whatever go to the mmm podcast com
this weekend I'm gonna be down in La
Jolla California just outside of San
Diego playing the Comedy Store my home
away from home out here in LA I'm gonna
do the one down in La Jolla and bring
your ass down there I got a brand new
Irish [ __ ] and I cannot wait to go down
there I'm gonna spend the [ __ ]
weekend down there get a sunburn on the
beach maybe do a little golfing and even
though I don't golf I just like [ __ ]
you know going out there and slowing it
down for the other country is and by the
way in two weeks I'm gonna be at the
Newport yawning Center in Newport Rhode
Island and I'm gonna be at the Hampton
Beach ballroom casino in Hampton New
Hampshire I gotta sell a ton of [ __ ]
tickets so if you're not doing anything
for the love of God you and all your
friends come on down get hammered if
you're the waitress from the cafe Venice
please show up I'll give you a DVD and
I'll give you the [ __ ] hundred bucks
with interest that I owe you from
[ __ ] goddamn 22 years ago all right
everybody
have a good week
[Music]
[Applause]
you